bonjour à tous et à toutes je voudrais
ouvrir cette première table ronde en
invitant les participants à me rejoindre
sur la scène tout d'abord marie noëlle
tine est chargée des relations
extérieures au cluster maritime français
un bel outil de promotion et de
développement pour notre économie
maritime je vais également accueillir
pierre georges dachicourt qui est
premier adjoint au maire de berck sur
mer président du conseil
d'administration du crédit maritime du
nord et qui a eu des responsabilités
éminentes nationale pour la pêche
française devrait accueillir le
président en exercice du comité national
des pêches gérard romiti qui nous fait
l'amitié d'être là ce soir et d'avoir
traversé la méditerranée pour rejoindre
le siège des républicains ce matin
daniel fasquelle député maire du touquet
qui est à cheval sur ces différentes
thématiques de la mer au touquet on est
toujours un char loisy assieds-toi
gérard et puis samia badat karam qui est
secrétaire général de la fédération des
entreprises d outre mer je n'ai oublié
personne
le sénateur jérôme bignon devait être
avec nous ce matin mais il est retenu au
sénat pour l'examen du projet de loi sur
la biodiversité et donc il ne sera pas
avec nous mais nous pensons à lui et
nous comptons sur lui pour ce projet
important
quelques mots d'introduction avant de
l'échanger avec nos différents
intervenants pour vous dire que la
puissance maritime de la france ne
pourra s'exprimer ne pourra être
reconquise que si nous respectons
l'environnement qui soutient cette
économie maritime dire que tous les
participants et les intervenants que
vous avez devant vous sont pleinement
conscients de l'impérieuse nécessité de
préserver nos océans et la qualité de
nos océans c'est la raison pour laquelle
il ya une parfaite concordance et
complémentarité entre les tables rondes
de ce matin environnement énergie est
maire il n'y aura pas de croissance
maritime durable sans respect durable du
milieu marin c'est une évidence que nous
rappellerons
tout au long de cette matinée pour
autant la mer est devenue un sujet à la
mode après la croissance bleue on a
entendu de plus en plus parler de la
croissance après la croissance verte
pardon nous avons de plus en plus
entendu parler de la croissance bleue et
les gens que vous avez devant vous ce
matin incarne une part de l'énergie de
l'énergie d'entreprise qui est employée
en faveur de cette croissance bleue et
donc nous allons commencer ces tables
rondes en en parlant tout d'abord du
commerce maritime et des ports avec
marie noëlle tine et puis nous parlerons
de la pêche et de la pêche durable et
enfin nous terminerons avec la
souveraineté maritime de la france et
notamment la souveraineté maritime de la
france outre-mer avec notre ami samia
badat cabalor premier temps de cette
table ronde
la question du commerce maritime et des
grands ports français et européen avec
marie noëlle tinée je vais m'asseoir
pour me joindre à vos bonjour bonjour ça
marche
bonjour bonjour à tous avant de avant de
commencer est ce que vous pouvez dire à
nos amis ce qu'est le cluster maritime
parce que c'est un nom qui nous est
familier mais peut-être que pour tout le
monde il n'est pas encore grand public
tout à fait écouter en tout cas merci
d'avoir invité le cluster maritime
français à votre table ronde le cluster
maritime français en fête existe depuis
maintenant 10 ans il a été donc créé par
et pour les professionnels de l'économie
maritime pour rassembler tous les
acteurs de l'économie maritime et
promouvoir cette économie maritime
aujourd'hui le cluster c400 entités
membres des pme des grands groupes des
fédérations des associations des régions
également et j'y reviendrai un peu plus
en détail la marine nationale également
et membre du cluster
on a trois axes de travail pour
renforcer la place maritime française la
communication institutionnelle
les synergies opérationnelles création
synergies
entre les différents acteurs et actions
d' influence pour je dirais introduire
aussi le monde
le pro bowl ha et l'économie maritime
française en fait j'aurais envie de
signaler enfin si vous l'avez pas vu
dans la presse
trois succès d'entreprises dcns qui
vient de décrocher un contrat géant pour
fournitures pour fournir douze sous
marins australiens donc se considérait
comme le contrat du siècle
autre exemple les chantiers stx qui
viennent de signer un nouvel accord avec
msc pour construire quatre nouveaux
paquebots et saint nazaire ça exactement
autre exemple cma-cgm leader mondial du
transport par conteneurs première matin
en france est en train de boucler
l'acquisition de nole qui est la plus
grande entreprise de transport maritime
d'asie du sud est
donc vous voyez critiquement avec trois
exemples comme ça on n'illustre quand
même le succès là des récents des
entreprises l'économie maritime ont dit
on dit que le secteur maritime français
c'est 300000 emplois et 70 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires est ce que ces
chiffres sont exacts oui tout à fait et
on les retrouve en fait si vous voulez
le cluster a fait cet exercice tous les
ans de compiler d'agréger les chiffres
de différents secteurs de l'économie
maritime
effectivement ça représente 300 mille
emplois et 70 milliards de valeur de
production pour donc 2015
on dit aussi que 90% des marchandises
transitent par la mer et que finalement
le commerce maritime et le commerce t
rès c'est le même puisque les produits
transitent par la mer
comment fait-on demain pour tirer parti
de ce commerce maritime pour accroître
nos parts de marché et en commerce et
pour nos ports qu'elles sont quels sont
les réflexions du cluster sur le sujet
pour
alors pour accroître les parts de marché
effectivement faut qu'on soit beaucoup
plus compétitif ce soit pour les
entreprises et les ports pour parler
pour dire quelques mots des ports
effectivement aujourd'hui vous avez sept
grands ports maritimes français quatre
en outre-mer qui ont été donc mis en
place lors de la réforme portuaire en
aujourd'hui on voit que effectivement
les effets positifs de cette réforme
portuaire entre si on compare les
chiffres sur le trafic de conteneurs en
france une croissance de 4% entre 2013
et 2014
donc on a effectivement des ports qui
qui ont reconquérir reconquis pardon des
parts de marché et qui font face en même
temps une grande concurrence européenne
et les ports plus de 50% des du trafic
portuaire européens passent par quatre
ports européens qui sont anvers
rotterdam hambourg brême donc et encore
ne vais pas citer deux ports français
par non dans l'est on est on est
effectivement pas en bonne position au
niveau européen mais il ya encore eu
effectivement beaucoup de choses à faire
et les ports français ce bâtiment
aujourd'hui pour gagner à nouveau la
confiance des armateurs des chargeurs et
devenir des ports des portes d'entrée de
cette france maritime
c'est important de fictivement
poursuivre nos efforts sur sur les ports
l'idée c'est de ces de proposer une à
nouveau un nouveau projet pour les ports
français pour leur faire pour leur
permettre de devenir des ports européens
parce que la rotterdam effectivement
aspire un peu tout mais on a on a de
beauport en france le port de marseille
représente près de 50 mille salariés
travailleurs on a un grand port un repas
le havre paris et on a évidemment
dunkerque saint-nazaire et sait comment
est ce qu'on fait de nos ports mais la
question est ouverte aussi
aux autres intervenants ce matin comment
est ce qu'on fait de nos ports
métropolitains et outre-mer je voudrais
pas oublier l'outre-mer qui tient une
part essentielle des ports de niveau
supérieur de niveau européen
là où aujourd'hui le transit commercial
nous échappe assez largement
est ce que il faut faire attention aussi
à il ya une réforme en 2008 qui a
effectivement créé des effets positifs
on le voit aujourd'hui
maintenant il faut être prudent et les
ports aujourd'hui ont gagné en stabilité
au niveau même sociale et il faut être
prudent aussi à l'avenir pour je dirais
avant de se lancer éventuellement dans
une nouvelle réforme
les porcs ont besoin de voilà de
stabilité et de confiance 1 auprès de
leurs clients et donc ça c'est important
je dirais aussi à l'avenir d'avoir ça en
tête
il faut effectivement les soutenir dans
leur développement dans leurs
investissements
adapter les gérer les politiques les
régimes fiscaux
voilà les aider aussi je pense aller à
l'international être plus présent à
l'international parce qu'effectivement
il faut aller conquérir des parts de
marché à l'international
donc voilà c'est ce que je dirai sur la
gouvernance il est souvent évoquée c'est
un peu l'idée que nous proposons aux
républicains souvent évoquée d'accroître
la part du privé dans la gestion des
ports c'est à dire de ne pas les laisser
dominer par la puissance publique mais
de de programmer et de bâtir une
gouvernance qui ressemble davantage à un
fonctionnement privé et notamment à au
fonctionnement des sociétés anonymes
dont l'état évidemment c'est
actionnaires mais qui permettrait une
plus grande souplesse une plus grande
réactivité et une plus grande part du
privé dans la participation des ports
c'est vrai que la réforme de 2008 avait
déjà introduit un certain nombre
d'effets positifs sur la gouvernance des
ports et vous avez salué ses
conséquences positives mais on se on a
envie aujourd'hui d'aller plus loin pour
dépasser le stade actuel est peut-être
pour réfléchir sur comment dirais-je des
des fonctionnements et des ambitions
portuaire par bassin cercle on a
évidemment le trafic commercial or en
méditerranée n'est pas celui de la
manche et les enjeux de concurrence avec
rotterdam sont pas les mêmes et donc à
travers une stratégie industrielle
maritime nouvelle et portuaire on peut
peut-être à l'échelle nationale dire
commencer à concevoir une autre
gouvernance et des ambitions plus
régionaliser pour les ports français
est-ce qu en outre-mer les les questions
portuaire se se pose de cette même façon
grâce à nos outre-mer on a notamment
grand port de la réunion une liaison
directe maintenant avec l'inde et la
chine qui effectivement insuffisamment
exploitées d'accord je reviens au
commerce maritime si vous voulez bien on
a un pavillon français avec
effectivement des figures de proue comme
cma-cgm on a parlé comme légitime
objet de fierté nationale mais la part
de trafic commercial sous pavillon
français décroît malheureusement qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour améliorer notre
nos parts de marché et pour soutenir
davantage notre pavillon français qu'est
ce que le le cluster
suggère et recommande dans ce domaine
déjà pour pour effectivement c'est
important de souligner la le dire la
cour les compagnies maritimes
aujourd'hui on la france compte un
pavillon d'excellence les armateurs
français s'engage pour la sécurité pour
l'innovation pour le respect de
l'environnement
la flotte de commerce représente 22
mille emplois 35 milliards de valeur de
production
on assistait cma-cgm et on a aussi des
fleurons dans l'industrie transport
maritime comme louis dreyfus armateurs
aussi batani ferry spécialisé dans le
trafic de passagers et de fret
premier employeur de marins français on
compte aussi des entreprises
spécialisées dans les services offshore
avec les entreprises leaders comme
bourbon technip au cg et les entreprises
les compagnies maritimes effectivement
ont besoin d'être soutenus par l'état et
notamment de pouvoir financer le
renouvellement de la flotte de leur
navire donc ça c'est un point important
ils l'ont déjà signalé pour
effectivement je dirais progresser et
gagner des parts de marché il ya
effectivement un problème de financement
ou de films de renouvellement de la
flotte et son financement mais aussi en
orientant ce financement sur des
solutions techniques qu'ils soient plus
protectrices de l'environnement qui soit
plus durable on part on pense notamment
aux modes de à l'énergie employée avec
la promotion du gaz liquéfié et avec
toutes les problématiques qui qui ont
très justement à l'économie d'énergie
pour le transport maritime m6 et le
transport qui est le moins carbonées et
qui a le moins d'impact sur
l'environnement par rapport aux
transporteurs et encore plus par rapport
au transport aérien
on doit les uns et les autres s'engager
davantage sur un transport maritime plus
économes en énergie
et donc plus propre transport bar team
plus sûre plus propre et fectivement
plus économe et c'est donc ça les
armateurs français il travaille je dirai
au quotidien c'est c'est une
préoccupation majeure pour eux quand
vous parlez de compétitivité du pavillon
français vous pensez à quoi au droit du
travail c'est un sujet d'actualité
aujourd'hui notamment l'assemblée
nationale puisque c'est le jour où on
examine en séance le projet de loi
travail quand vous parlez compétitives
ou par vous pensez de retravailler ou
penser à autre chose
compétitivité je dirais effectivement
sur la place un terrain au niveau
international en fait pour effectivement
ils ont enfin il ya eu d'ailleurs une
loi pour la loi de croissance bleue dans
le roi aussi qu effectivement apporté
beaucoup de je dirais d'éléments et donc
effectivement nous nous donne vraiment
de l'espoir pour quelque chose change de
nom et vos alliés dans la bonne voie
comme ça fait partie des éléments
positifs récents aussi de apportés par
cette loi croissance bleue on a comme
toujours d'un sujet là des satisfactions
mais aussi des sujets d'agacement
puisque la france est championne du
monde de la sueur transposition des
directives européennes et c'est le cas
notamment en droit du travail pour les
marins et si déjà on se contentait de
transposer de manière équitable entre
les pays européens on gagnerait déjà en
compétitivité par rapport ne serait ce
qu'à nos voisins puisque le coût des
marins français et de 40% plus élevé que
celui des marins l'italien pour ne citer
qu'eux merci marine matinée de ce
premier échange mais je vous invite à
intervenir par la suite sur le sur le
déroulez des tables rondes si vous
voulez dans un deuxième temps on
souhaite aborder la question de la pêche
parce que la pêche française c'est non
seulement une activité économique de
premier plan mais c'est aussi une
activité économique culturelle
identitaire pour les porcs et les
façades maritimes gérard romiti on
entend beaucoup parler des nuages qui
assombrissent l'horizon de la pêche
française
alors est-ce que la pêche française a
encore un avenir je vous taquine un peu
un le matin
mais surtout je suis à côté de mon
prédécesseur donc il faut que je fasse
très attention puisque jorge était le
président du comité national des pêches
et boulonnais en plus donc oui la pêche
à l avenir
j'y crois puisque je suis là ils ont
besoin de soutien de la part des élus et
depuis que je suis élu je sais de tisser
le lien termeer et les passerelles que
nous faisons aussi au sein de l'anel et
je dirais que nous sommes en train de
maritime is est un peu cette france ces
députés français ces sénateurs qui ne
pas tous ne savent que l'eau de mer et
les salles et je vais vous est taquin
vous aussi voilà donc les quelques
députés parlementaires ici daniel gibbs
notre députés ultramarins et puis tiens
je tiens aussi à souligner le travail
que vous avez fait avec votre groupe
ainsi qu'à la loire dont le roi quand
même qui était une loi très importante
mais c'est vrai que nous sommes en
pleine mutation nous aussi donc
statistiques mondiales
mon pack française un emploi en merde
c'est trois emplois induits à terre
trois emplois du inter donc la pêche
française
aujourd'hui ces 48 mille quatre cent
trente et une entreprise d'emplois
directs emplois directs s'est multiplié
par trois
7160 bateau avec une prédominance de
base de petits bateaux de moins de 12
mètres qui représente 80 % cela c'est
loin de l'image et des a priori que les
médias véhiculent souvent sous la pêche
des grands bateaux qui détruisent tout
sur leur passage c'est ce qu'ont c'est
l'image qu'on essaye de coller à la
pêche française pour nos possédant notre
frotte 40 bateaux de plus de 40 mètres
le chiffre donc bon voilà donc les
choses sont claires je sens inverse ça
représente 4000 quelques entreprises et
39 crier sur nos ports plus les gens qui
sont hors crié des organisations de
producteurs et c'est là donc la pêche
veut croire son avenir alors lorsque les
politiques disent la france deuxième
puissance pas eu et on n'a pas encore
dit ce matin on va le dire la terreur
sans doute mais mais mais en s'en
gargarise pas donc il faut aussi
protéger cette grande mère donc si vous
voulez les pêcheurs nous travaillons
dans alors on croit à l'avenir même si
on a des doutes même souvent on a des
doutes
nous travaillons sur le pêcheur du futur
sur le bateau du futur et je crois que
le patron pêcheur et l'armateur que je
suis telles que je les ai été pendant 27
ans ou 30 ans maintenant le temps passe
pour moi aussi il faut évoluer ce statut
là nous avons besoin de relais nous
avons besoin de financer l'installation
des jeunes par des bateaux nouvelle
génération comme vous le soulignez alors
à quoi il ressemble le bateau du futur
le bateau de pêche du futur je pense
qu'ils les bateaux de pêche du futur
parce que je représente aussi les dom le
comité national représente les dom ils
sont membres du cluster nous participons
ensemble aussi
donc mettre au point un bateau du futur
pour la marine marchande peut être aussi
avoir des retombées sur la marine
j'aiderai nationale et même la marine de
pêche alors le bateau et je pense que je
m'avance un peu le bateau du futur ne
peut pas être qu'un seul bateau de
futures il peut avoir des bateaux de
futures selon les territoires selon les
régions par exemple le bateau de konami
en place sur bologne qui est pionnier
avec un suivi l'arpège ne peut pas être
valable peut-être dans les dom ou en
méditerranée
chez moi donc voilà donc il faut
travailler il n'y a pas un modèle il
faut travailler en concertation avec les
professionnels
je veux faire un petit clin d'oeil à
l'europe je pense que l'europe pêche non
pas d'abord des cerveaux des des gens
mais il faut qu'elle se rapproche plus
des techniciens le savoir-faire
empirique que nous savons nous les
pêcheurs
il faut le transmettre aux générations
futures et ce savoir faire
les eurodéputés que je que je respecte
les scientifiques que je respecte encore
plus puisque nous avons besoin d'eux
pour aujourd'hui travailler sur les
quotas de pêche
il faut qu'ils se rapprochent des
techniciens et souvent je pense que
c'est il faut parler d'une méthode
la méthode se mettre autour d'une table
et travailler tous ensemble vers un
futur donc le statut de pêcheurs à mon
avis tel que je le connais moi c'est à
dire nous sommes
je vous fait rire nous sommes encore et
nous y tenons beaucoup rénumérés à la
part c'est à dire que nous avons un
salaire fixe dans les droits sociaux le
pavillon français premier registre
ça fait partie aussi de nos de nos
revendications que nous y tenons c'est à
dire nous sommes nous avons une caisse
qui s'appelle les nîmes qui est une des
plus belles fesses de france
et nous ne sommes pas des retraités nous
sommes des pensionnés nous sommes des
pensionnés donc ça veut dire que nous
avons ce statut qui est quand même très
particulier bon il ya 47 mille retraités
pour 10 7 me d'actifs aujourd'hui donc
il faut faire très attention
nous avons besoin de conserver ce savons
faire et surtout ce que vous le disiez
tout à l'heure c'est cette transmission
je dirais sociaux économiques et
culturels
il ya une identité côtière mais on a
évolué aujourd'hui nous revendiquons le
droit à produire nous sommes et nous
voulons déjà reconquérir le marché
français avec françois pécheux pavillon
france faut savoir que la france importe
80 % de sa consommation
c'est considérable c'est une folie nous
on n'a pas le droit d'aller pêcher des
poissons parce que nous n'avons pas les
quotas ont dit y a du bon sens il faudra
le prouver il paraît qu'il a plus de
poisson mais qu'est ce que vous les
péchés il ya plus de pression c'est ce
qu'on nous explique à longueur de temps
il ya plus de poissons il reste du
poisson où il ya plus d'une façon je
crois que pierre georges souris du
poisson ce qui vont même le dimanche
dans la pêche de loisir savent qu'il ya
du poisson c'est les pêcheurs qui manque
aujourd'hui c'est un métier qui nourrit
son homme faut savoir qu'un marin
pêcheur aujourd'hui je pense de le dire
devant la salle je crois qu'on a eu tort
de ne pas le dire plus souvent sur les
gagne très bien sa vie
on ne connaît pas le chômage on se bat
pour le chômage en france
ben on se bat pour avoir des marins qui
veulent venir sur nos bateaux avec des
salaires pas toujours bien sûr puisqu'il
ya une rémunération à la part vous avez
la catégorie des salaires qui varient
entre quelqu'un qui ne sait rien faire
1500 euros quelqu'un qui a quelques
brevets il en a quatre mille à l'année
je trouve que c'est pas mal un capitaine
de pêche peut gagner jusqu'à 2500 euros
ceux qui ont des enfants qui sont allés
en pha qui ont fait dix ans de faim que
j'aimerais bien savoir leur salaire
parce que votre serviteur en a deux qui
ont fait beaucoup d'études
donc ça me et puis la sortie c'est papa
et maman qui s'en occupe toujours parce
qu'ils ont des salaires loin de ce camp
mais marin alors moi même ça c'est des
propos attractif pour le pour la ville y
affecter vivement pour la jeunesse c'est
le plus beau métier du monde vous pouvez
commencer comme simple marin vous allez
à l'école vous passez vos modules vous
devenez second patron capitaine et votre
propre armateurs je crois que vous en
avez deux là on est quand même n'a pas
trop pas trop rougir je pense ça va pas
trop maigre donc voilà on paye des
impôts on est content de payer et je
vous dire alors après le souci je veux
pas être trop long j'essaye de g je
surveille le chrono j'ai sauvé beaucoup
de notes donc
comment faire pour accéder à la
propriété il ya des écoles nous avons
douze écoles en france qui sont très
bien mais il ya un problème après le
métier peut-être a subi beaucoup d'
attaques de certaines ong
j'ai bien de certaines ong pas tout
parce que et on est toujours en train de
se justifier nous sommes la variante
d'ajustement des pouvoirs politiques qui
sont en place et de ceux qui vont venir
peut-être donc nous voulons art est
arrêté j'espère arrêtez de nous pas de
nous de vous servir de nous nous nous
avons le droit et le devoir de nourrir
les gens nous allons la terre va passer
à 9 milliards d'habitants aujourd'hui la
pêche nourrit 7 milliards à peu près
l'aquaculture c'est un fiasco que je
défends aussi parce que me représentant
la culture vous savoir que la france
était pionnière dans les années 80 nous
sommes la lanterne rouge
un petit warning sur l'aquaculture nous
importons 80%
sur les importations 90% et sur les 90%
d'importation nous recevrons de la chine
du vietnam 75 % d'asie sert nos enfants
dans les cantines aux petits enfants
mangent du pain gars alors qu'ils
pourraient manger du cabillaud ou
d'autres espèces
et ça je tiens à vous le dire parce que
je pense pas qu'on vous le disent dans
toutes les réunions
tu as raison de dire ja dans la cantine
d'olonne sur mer
on ne sert que du poisson de la criée
des sables d'olonne en un peu en
contradiction avec les règles des
marchés publics mais on va quand même
pas offrir du panda ou tanga où je suis
pas quoi à nos enfants de l'homme alors
qu'on a une grille avec du poisson frais
et bio à côté pierre georges dachicourt
sur vous et élu local aujourd'hui après
avoir été présent du congo messieurs
brian d'arcy et pêcheur devant l'éternel
et vous est aussi président du conseil
d'admistration du crédit maritime du
nord qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
localement dans un port dans une cité
dans un département maritime pour
soutenir la pêche artisanale française
alors deux petits exemples d'abord
bonjour à tous messieurs et mesdames
ça fait vraiment très plaisir d'être là
et celle qui m'a attiré ici je tiens
vraiment à lui tirer un grand coup de
chapeau ses ventes vont te noies non
parce que c'est une fille extraordinaire
on aura l'occasion c'est vraiment
quelqu'un d'exceptionnel dans le groupe
des républicains
je vais vous donner un tout petit
exemple 2013 une année une fin d'année
sombre crédit maritime appuyé évidemment
un autre groupe qui est populaire les
banques populaires bpce
évidemment vu que crédit maritime n'a
plus vraiment les moyens financiers et
de volants nécessaire à répondre aux
normes bancaires européennes et
mondiales malheureusement 2013 caisse
crédit maritime région nord c'est-à-dire
dunkerque le havre investissements
vraiment triste ou les moins de 4
millions d'encours
donc on peut pas dire de près
fait 2015 eh bien on est passé à 12
millions d'euros
on nouvellement de la flottille un des
premiers bateaux du futur qui étaient
inscrits dans le grand emprunt d'une
certaine époque un peu plus facile pour
la pêche où on avait fait inscrire et là
j'étais encore en poste à la place de
gérard avec hubert carrez le dg la du
comité national qui est là cachées
derrière eh bien on avait fait inscrire
quatre bateaux type dans le grand
emprunt c'est vrai que le ster
d'ailleurs ils nous avaient regardé avec
des grands yeux parce que les pêcheurs
n'allez pas nous pou fé l'enveloppent
mais n'ont elles pas bouffer le globe
on a pris notre part et à partir de là
il ya eu premier bateau qui est sorti
l'année dernière sur boulogne-sur-mer
qui est un vraiment un prototype
également qui dit prototype 10,8
millions 8 millions d'investissements
pour un bateau de 24 m il faut quand
même avoir ces chiffres là l'esprit vous
imaginez le simple artisan lambda qui
arrive qui va voir sa bande qui dit bah
écoute et voilà avec tous les aides que
je vais avoir entre emprunts ceci cela
il me faut quand même trois millions et
demi d'euros d'emprunts c'est pas facile
hein c'est pas facile lorsqu'il est
encore moins facile c'est comment les
banques par rapport à ça arrive à se
situer sur le business plan du bateau
c'est pour ça qu'on tient et qu'on veut
tout le monde et à ses partisans de
partir sur des quotas pluriannuel de
façon à avoir un business plan qui est
établie au minimum sur 2 voire cinq ans
c'est capital
c'est capital parce que si chaque année
on est suspendue à un droit de pêche qui
va soit croissance soit des croissants
et plutôt un peu décroissance est très
compliqué pour une banque de prêter
alors évidemment il ya un appui
maintenant qui quand même considérable
par rapport aux artisans c'est qu'on
peut appeler la bpi sur les garanties
ça évite aussi d'hypothéquer comme
disait souvent gérard grand-père
l'arrière grand-père et puis des morts
qui sont dans le cercueil
et parfois c'est compliqué donc c'est
vraiment très important
bon reste que bpi le ticket quand même
assez cher
j'avoue franchement que quand on prend
un ticket pays
ça reste environ pratiquement 1% de taux
d'emprunt malgré que les taux ont quand
même vraiment très bien a baissé
je pense que actuellement sur les
bateaux on est en train de mettre en
place
on tourne entre 1,80 et de 10 de taux de
financement d'une entreprise sur une
valeur de trois millions trois millions
et demi d'euros dont vous voyez ça reste
quand même relativement correct cette
chose c'est que là dedans il faut
appuyer le bpi
donc ça gonfle quand même aussi la
facture ça c'est quand même la réflexion
qu'il faudra avoir vraiment longtemps et
puis malgré la fuite en avant
malheureusement de nos grands bateaux il
ya des gens qui y croient et puisqu'on
en a je parle vraiment pour la région
nord parce que je peux je n'ai pas
vraiment regardé le reste on a trois
nouvelles unités en construction des
bateaux de 24 mètres des garçons d'une
quarantaine d'années qui ont des bateaux
qui ont 27 28 ans et vous savez c'est
fini en roulant de chaud hein
il faut qu'on soit peut-être pas dans
les rolls mais dans des très très belles
unités de pêche pour à tracter avoir une
attractivité du métier les jeunes ils en
ont marre d'aller dans des bateaux qui
sont vieillissants dire quand on rentre
dans une unité de 25 mètres mais qui à
25 ans d'âge c'est patrice temps donc si
je vous écoute le bateau de pêche du
futur qu'ont commencé à dessiner tout à
l'heure avec gérard romiti il est plus
grand que la moyenne de la flotte
aujourd'hui il peut être de 24 m non il
faut qu'ils soient en adéquation avec le
secteur de pêche représentés c'est à
dire qu'il nous faut absolument avoir de
ses unités là pour continuer aller
pêcher nos quotas de pêche parce que
vous quand même avoir l'esprit que
malheureusement on laisse plus de 40
mille tonnes de quotas de pêche à l'eau
faute d'unité faute d'unité
ça c'est très important à savoir donc
c'est ça l'important
je veux pas flatté député fasquelle pas
ce qu'on va dire évidemment c'est un
copain 1 on a le sénateur rapin qui est
là également à vous dire c'est du
copinage mais il y avait eu à l'époque
un très très bon rapport de fait sur le
renouvellement de la flottille bon
malheureusement les choses étant ce
qu'elles sont je pense qu'il doit être
même pas dans un fonds de tiroirs les
ans du déchet mais non à des exemplaires
on peut s'en servir aussi pour faire
développer
donc c'est un bateau d'abord qui doit
être économe en énergie
c'est capital comment il l'est davantage
qu'aujourd'hui alors comment il l'est
d'abord on a travaillé sur les carènes
des bateaux ce qui est très important
sur la propulsion qui est forcément très
souvent une proposition hybride
on avait les technologies qui existaient
et c'est pour ça que gérard a insisté
avec le cluster c'est vrai je pense que
l'automobile a évolué grâce à la formule
1 eh ben c'est le même principe il ya
des technologies exceptionnelle chez
dcns et autres je cite ce nom comme ça
et on ne sait pas aller les chercher
pour les appliquer à des plus petites
unités
il ya des gens qui ont besoin de bateau
de 15 mètres et qui en vivent très très
bien il ya des gens et je suis persuadé
qu'ils ont besoin de bateaux de 25 m je
pense que le temps des 40 50 m est
révolu je vais vous dire pourquoi elle
est révolue parce que malheureusement on
a laissé échapper grande partie de nos
quotas à des fonds de pension américains
qui ont été capables de monter des
randos holding via l'islande
les hollandais et les britanniques qui
ont racheté actuellement ces fonds
pension détiennent 80% 80% des espèces
pélagiques de poisson bleu c'est à dire
maquereau hareng et autres on ne le sait
pas quand il ya quelques années j'ai
crié j'ai dit attention les américains
sont en train de bouffer ils l'ont fait
ils ont acheté des bateaux en france
euronor été complètement hd comme à
pêche qui fait du sur emi à 50 % en
irlande qui l'ibex qui était le plus
grand port pélagiques d'europe a été
racheté il ya 80% par ses fonds de
pension
tout ça c'est en train de nous échapper
c'est mondialisée c'est normal bien sûr
mais c'est celui des quotas qui nous
échappe à nous en vous écoutant pierre
georges dachicourt et géant remettions
on comprend bien que le métier de
marin-pêcheur c'est c'est un métier de
chef d'entreprise d'entrepreneurs qui
investissent beaucoup d'argent et qui
est dont le modèle économique repose sur
la capacité l'accès à la ressource et
l'accès à la ressource
c'est une décision qui se prend
annuellement aujourd'hui à bruxelles par
le conseil des ministres européens de la
pêche sur proposition la commission et
débats au parlement daniel fasquelle
il vient souvent tous les ans
régulièrement pour soutenir le marché
longtemps comment est ce que est ce que
ce système là est satisfaisant ce
système de tac et quotas annuels daniel
fasquelle est ce que vous voulez nous
dit un petit mot là dessus ou qui
traînait à bruxelles tous les ans au
moment fatidique
mais bonjour a tous je veux remercier
très sincèrement mode
d'abord on a beaucoup de chance de
l'avoir c'est vrai aux républicains
c'est important qu'on parle de
l'environnement est important aussi
qu'on parle de la pêche d'avoir fait une
place à la pêche artisanale ce matin
dans le cadre de cette convention c'est
un signe fort parce que c'est vrai que
on se sent toujours un peu esseulé quand
on parle de ces questions et on voit le
manque d'intérêt pour ces questions
malheureusement à l'assemblée nationale
peut être aussi au sénat et s'agissant
de ces négociations de fin d'année à
bruxelles sachez qu'on est souvent très
très peu nombreux pendant des années
j'étais avec louis guédon on était deux
députés français en tout et pour tout
pour soutenir nos marins pêcheurs dans
les négociations de fin d'année
maintenant on se retrouve à deux avec
yannick moreau la président de la
commission pêche de l'assemblée
nationale membre de la majorité n'est
même pas présente à l'occasion de ces
négociations de fin d'année alors qu'il
faut être là pour soutenir nos marins
pêcheurs là donc c'est important que les
républicains montrent tout l'intérêt
qu'ils portent à cette activité qui
certes quand on regarde le produit
intérieur brut français
l'activité de la pêche c'est pas grand
chose mais par contre là où la pêche est
présente c'est essentiel parce que c'est
parfois 50 60 70 % 80% de l'activité que
de mixer des familles qui en vivent les
emplois directs et indirects
il faut vraiment en avoir conscience et
la france c'est un malheureusement un
pays de terriens alors que la france est
une façade maritime absolument
incroyable en france et outre-mer cher
daniel et on en a pas suffisamment
conscience il faut qu'on défende cette
façade maritime les activités maritimes
et la pêche c'est essentiel et c'est le
message
moi je crois qu'il faut retenir de cette
convention ce matin alors après
s'agissant des sujets qui nous
intéressent
tu parlais négociations de fin d'année à
bruxelles enfin que le point de départ
est le problème vient des constats
scientifiques
est ce que les scientifiques sont
capables de dire très exactement qui
sont les stocks de poissons la vérité
c'est que non est ce que les
scientifiques dialogue avec les marins
pêcheurs quant aux cons ça qu'ils
peuvent faire eux mêmes quant à
l'évolution de ses stocks de poissons la
vérité c'est que non en tous les cas
très insuffisamment or toute la
politique commune des pêches repose sur
des constats scientifiques y sont pas
solides qui sont pas fiables et ça pose
évidemment des problèmes tout à fait
considérable donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment mettre l'accent là dessus on
n'a peut-être pas fait suffisamment
peut-être mettre plus de moyens entre
les mains dit frais mer est plus à l
écoute des marins pêcheurs pour qu'on
ait des bases scientifiques solides
cantons fixent les quotas qu'on dise pas
voilà telle espèce de poisson est en
danger alors qu'en fait c'est le
contraire et que du coup mettre des
grands coups de rabots on déstabilise
des états des entreprises de pêche alors
qu'en réalité on n'a aucune raison de le
faire et ça crée vraiment un malaise et
des tensions voilà je crois que tant
qu'on n'aura pas travailler sur ces
constats scientifiques et tant qu'ils
seront pas solides on aura ces tensions
alors sur la base de ces constats
scientifiques ensuite il faut lisser les
choses dans le temps on peut pas comme
ça chaque année en fin d'année remettre
en cause la vie d'entreprise et donc
derrière les emplois directs et
indirects qui en dépendent
sur des négociations de fin d'année qui
sont des négociations qui repose sur des
constats qui sont pas solides parfois en
décalage
parce que l'évolution des stocks de
poisson peut être très rapide et on voit
qu'il ya parfois il ya un décalage entre
ce qui est décidé à bruxelles par
rapport à ce qui était constaté deux
trois ans auparavant puisque et puis et
puis et puis la réalité
puis chaque année bas c'est tout tout
est remis en cause et c'est impossible
bien je le disais gérard aussi pour des
entreprises ce sont des entreprises de
pouvoir se projeter dans l'avenir
sachant que vos recettes
donc les quotas sont remis en cause
chaque année et donc il faut absolument
obtenir de lisser les choses dans le
temps pour répondre à ta question et
yannick bru rivaux et douala et moi je
défends mais toi aussi et je pense que
ce sera l'une des productions des
républicains de faire en sorte que ces
quotas soient pluriannuel et qu'on lis
les choses à la hausse
ce qu'il faut pas hésiter à augmenter
les quotas quand c'est possible à la
baisse quand évidemment une espèce est
en danger parce que d'ailleurs les
marins pêcheurs sur les premières
d'avoir conscience vider la mer de ces
poissons c'est
détruire leur outil de travail l or en
tous les cas la ressource et pêcheurs en
ont besoin ils souhaitent aussi la
préserver il faut le faire dans le
dialogue avec eux par rapport à des
conseils scientifiques qui sont lissées
dans le temps il ya aussi la question
des mesures techniques parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des quotas il ya aussi des
mesures techniques qui sont aberrantes
et qui ne sont pas suffisamment
régionalisée et adaptées aux différents
types de pêche la pêche bretonne par
exemple c'est une pêche qui est très
ciblé où on peut d'ailleurs loin des
côtes parfois allait cibler une espèce
en particulier dans le pas de calais
dans le détroit du pas de calais c'est
une pêche multi-espèces quand vous
lancez vos fils et bien vous pouvez pas
dire je verrai jamais récupéré qu'un
type de poisson est forcément bien les
mesures techniques et les quotas ne
peuvent pas être appliqué la même façon
d'une zone de pêche à une autre alors la
régionalisation elle est en cours mais
il faut aller encore plus loin je crois
que c'est un point qu'on peut retenir
également
et puis géant terminerait simplement sur
les à propos des navires de pêche je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet parce que
la flotte de pêche vie considérablement
à la demande de françois fillon j'avais
fait un rapport au premier ministre
en 2000 en fin 2011 début 2012 que
malheureusement les socialistes sont en
empressé de mettre dans un placard
ce qui est tout à fait dommage que
j'avais fait deux propositions la
première c'est de revoir complètement
les règles sur la jauge parce que c'est
un vrai sujet est un vrai souci pour
pouvoir construire deux des navires plus
plus performant mais également que de
meilleures conditions de travail à bord
et puis par ailleurs et c'est un échec
pour moi considérable des socialistes à
bruxelles dans le cadre du nouveau fonds
européens de la pêche nouveau fait amp
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui aider
financièrement à la construction de
nouveaux navires
or ça coûte très très cher et il ya une
marche qui est beaucoup trop haute pour
beaucoup de de deux jeunes marins
pêcheurs il faut absolument y va
déverrouiller ça et faire en sorte qu'on
puisse aider aussi à la construction de
nouveaux navires
et pourquoi bruxelles refuse d'aider à
la construction de nouveaux navires
j'ai interpellé le commissaire européen
à la pêche qui a quinze jours à
l'assemblée
il m'avait promis de me répondre par
écrit l'a fait je vous remets très la
lettre et s'agissant des nouveaux
navires de pêche
il me répond que
ils ne sont que bruxelles ne veut pas
aider à la construction de nouveaux
navires
pourquoi parce que cela va augmenter la
capacités des flottes de pêche
ils ont tout faux il faut des nouveaux
navires pourquoi parce que des nouveaux
navires vont consommer moins de
carburant et c'est exactement l'inversé
on a des vieux navires la moyenne d'âge
de la flotte de pêche ses 26 27 ans ces
navires consomme trop de carburant et
pour équilibrer les budgets des
entreprises
il faut pêcher plus pour pouvoir payer
la facture de carburant alors qu'avec
des nouveaux navires moins consommateur
de carburant on va baisser la facture et
on va lutter justement contre la
surpêche
mais on n'arrive pas à faire passer ce
message dans tous les cas gouvernement a
pas été capable de faire passer ce
message dont je crois qu'il faut
vraiment défendre avec force cette idée
qu'il faut revoir les règles sur la
jauge on a transposé bêtement merci dans
les règles de la belote avec des navires
de commerce aux navires de pêche et puis
il faut aussi une politique forte pour
aider à la construction de nouveaux
navires parce que on a besoin de
pêcheurs en france si on a besoin de
préserver de soutenir cette belle
activité merci merci daniel pour ses
éclairages on voit la passion que tu
mets dans la défense de la pêche
artisanale j'aurais donné le mot de la
fin pour ce volet pêche à gérard romiti
pour qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour attirer les jeunes dans le contexte
et dans le paysage qu'on vient de
décrire comment comment est-ce qu'on
renouvelle les marins pêcheurs
je vois que il ya des élus qui
connaissent la pêche s'est passé les
armateurs pas encore donc et puis la
banque qui va financer le crédit
maritime est très important c'est notre
banque qui nous soutient alors les
finances il faut des finances ne suffit
pas il faut changer le mode actuelle les
statuts du pêcheur la passation
d'entreprise aussi c'est quelque chose
de très important
vous avez entendu les chiffres que
pierre georges nous a dit je vais
revenir sur un bateau beaucoup plus
modeste 1,12 m aujourd'hui ces sept cent
mille euros 700 vélos donc il faut avoir
formé les 30% les cautions à terre mais
un père qui par exemple quelqu'un qui
veut passer à son fils une passation
d'entreprise sur un bateau d'un million
d'euros il va payer 600 mille euros de
plus values et les élus luz mais on va
arranger sa valeur non si on arrive
c'est bien aussi vous arriver demain à
faire que nous ayons des quotas
pluriannuel c'est notre rêve le battrons
pour ça je pense que c'est parce que
c'est il ya la roulette russe
mais la roulette bruxelles oise très peu
de gens le lacaunais si encore elle est
pire encore donc lorsque vous mettez des
hommes comme ça sur la table que vous
êtes une petite pme ou une grande pme il
faut que la banque vous suivent
il faut qu'on puisse par exemple c'est
le cas sur bologne je félicite quand
même boulogne c'est une région les
ouvrir et scorer nam
on va mettre encore deux bateaux le 5
mai ya de bateaux pour deux armements
bretons qui vont aller à l'eau donc des
armements qui construisent deux bateaux
de la somme qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
par an donc des amendes qui investissent
donc à un moment donné est ce qu'on est
vu comme une économie où est-ce qu'on
est comme dit comme les fameux
régulateur de environnementaux donc il
faut surtout ne cédez pas le pas soyez
ferme je pense ce que demanderait la
profession demain les jeunes nous
travaillons pépinière d'entreprises le
bateau du futur comme les pierres
georges
il faut avoir envie d'aller on n'a plus
envie d'aller sur il faut humaniser
vous savez ils ont des bateaux avec des
cabinets aujourd'hui il faut moi même
j'ai perdu des marins parce que il y
avait le trou noir jais mais qu'est ce
que sera le trou noir j'ai pourtant vous
avez bien pêcher mehdi même monsieur
rometty de l'internet ne passe pas ah
bon j'aurais jamais cru ça que vous
perdiez marin parce qu'il peut pas
tweeté peut pas communiquer tous les
soirs d un chéri je suis là je précis
j'ai préservé
il faut lui il faut faire en sorte
qu'internet passe donc c'est ça le futur
aussi donc c'est une vision nouvelle
dans le respect de la ressource les
quotas je pense que c'est pas mal
arrivé à avoir des quotas mais seulement
là aussi le paquet je dirais pêcheurs
scientifiques bruxelles
mais quand vous avez une vraie mère qui
est un désengagement total je tiens à le
dire ici d engagement total des frais
mer donc
l'institut français je dirais le tampon
ifremer et nous le faut c'est en nous
l'envient dont je dirais dans le monde
entier mais aujourd'hui ce que disait
pierre georget la houppe est rouvert un
peu une brèche je conclurai sur ça les
anglais le british là en ce moment on a
surpris quelques courriers du ministre
écossais qui dit nous allons boutre les
français dehors de nos zones de pêche
si ça passe les espagnols ont acheté des
droits de pêche les feux les fameux
fonds de pension américains sont rentrés
par l'irlande par d'autres pays sont là
et les zones où on veut nous chasser
avec la pêche profonde via je veux pas
aborder ce sujet mais ont pour l'heure à
l'aborder une prochaine fois il faut
conclure sont les zones où enfin on va
on va on va faire des airs marines
protégées et des forages en mer
voilà donc on veut chasser les pêcheurs
français bonjour merci j'espère qu'on a
été assez clair merci beaucoup y a merci
à tous
la croissance bleue l'économie bleus
c'est évidemment les sujets convient et
vous d'évoquer méo beaucoup d'autres le
l'économie littoral l'économie
touristique cher à cher à mon collègue
rapin c'est évidemment des sujets
essentiels la construction navale en
général la construction navale de
plaisance la plaisance de tourisme etc
ce sont des sujets évidemment auquel
nous pensons mais que nous n'avons pas
le temps d'aborder complètement ce matin
je devrai simplement qu'on fasse un
détour vers l'essentiel de notre espace
maritime français puisque 90% des fameux
11 millions de kilomètres carrés
d'espacé maritime sous juridiction
française sont évidemment outre mer donc
je voudrais donner la place
qui lui revient à l'outre-mer à travers
notre ami samia badat karam qui est
secrétaire général de la fédération des
entreprises d'outre-mer pour lui poser
la question simplement de savoir comment
est ce que le l'outre-mer peut tirer
parti de cette croissance bleue et peut
prendre toute sa part dans le
développement économique maritime de la
france
tout d'abord merci de m'avoir invité à
témoigner aujourd'hui sur les autres
maires effectivement on ne peut pas
faire une table ronde sur la mer sans
parler des outre-mer et et vous l'avait
bien dit 97% même de notre espace
maritime et outre-mer et on a parlé tout
à l'heure on a dit qu'on était la
deuxième puissance maritime on n'est pas
la deuxième puissance maritime on est le
deuxième domaine maritime en sera la
deuxième puissance maritime
le jour où on saura justement exploiter
ses ressources et je voudrais commencer
par quelques chiffres donc on a dit on
est donc le second domaine maritime
grâce à nos autres maires 80 % de la
biodiversité française se trouve dans
les autres mers et puis surtout grâce à
ces outre-mer la france est aujourd'hui
présente au coeur de tous les grands
courants de tous les grands carrefours
maritime
on est à côté du nouveau canal de panama
acp grâce aux antilles françaises n'est
ce pas cher daniel gibbs s'est pas c'est
pas toi qui me contredira on est
également grâce à aux grands ports de la
réunion dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
en liaison directe avec toute l'asie
donc c'est vraiment l'outre-mer qui est
au coeur de tout le développement
maritime français et puis les outre-mer
sont aussi c'est peut-être un peu moins
connus par les non initiés le théâtre de
projet technologique extrêmement avancé
je pense notamment au projet soit qu de
climatisation par extraction de mer en
eau profonde
je pense également à des projets comme
bioalgostral
d'exploitation des algues des
microalgues pour l'alimentation
l'énergie et les médicaments
une fois qu'on a dit tout ça
effectivement on voit aussi se dire
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui ses ressources
maritimes comptant l'outre-mer sont
insuffisamment exploitées et
insuffisamment protégé et le premier axe
de notre projet aux républicains c'est
de mieux protéger nos airs maritime et
notamment en renforçant la présence de
l'état dans les fameuses z2 les zones
économiques exclusives et concrètement
en se donnant les moyens donc de mieux
sécuriser puisqu'on sait enfin on en
parle souvent dans l'actualité ces zones
maritimes sont aujourd'hui victimes de
tout ce qui est piraterie de tout ce qui
est banditisme trafic d'êtres humains de
drogue au large de quoi donc on doit
l'état doit reprendre ses fonctions
régaliennes et mieux protéger nos
espaces maritimes donc l'affirmation de
notre souveraineté et la protection de
ses espaces maritimes passent par notre
présence physique sur place à travers
notre marine par exemple exactement nos
patrouilleurs sont en nombre insuffisant
aujourd'hui dont un effort de moyens
évident à produire pour ne serait-ce que
protéger le milieu sans parler même de
l'exploitation exactement le premier axe
fonctions régaliennes on voit mieux
protégés on doit se donner les moyens de
dégager un budget pour protéger nos
zones économiques exclusives que on a
réussi d'ailleurs a augmenté récemment
de 500 mille kilomètres carrés et on a
d'ailleurs encore grâce aux outremers
puisque grâce à saint pierre et miquelon
on pourrait même augmenter grâce à
l'extension du plateau continental près
d'un million de kilomètres carrés donc
tout ça c'est bien beau mais premier axe
sécuriser un programme de renouvellement
des patrouilleurs notamment bat simard
jusqu'en 2025 2030 qui est qui et qui
est aujourd'hui adoptée mais après il
faudra que nous veillions les uns et les
autres en faire une priorité budgétaire
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
est donc peut-être que la croissance
bleue
la croissance de l'économie maritime
métropolitaine et ultramarine permettra
justement de redonner un petit peu
d'oxygène
à nos finances publiques et de
réinvestir sur l'affirmation de notre
souveraineté
c'est j'imagine le soit aussi du cluster
sur sur le développement du tramway on
soutient complètement le développement
des clusters ultramarins faut savoir que
le cluster maritime a justement
favoriser la création de cette kloster
et comme effectivement vous l'avait dit
et c'est important de le protéger ses
espaces maritimes de prose protéger 7 et
2 e
on a besoin d'une marine nationale forte
avec des moyens en adéquation justement
à ces enjeux de protection de
l'environnement ces enjeux de protéger
nos espaces nos intérêts économiques
et c'est effectivement un élément
important pour le rayonnement de la
france pour la souveraineté de la france
on a besoin d'une grande marine alors
nous les métropolitains en images
on a une image un petit peu déformé
idéalisée de l'outre-mer de nos vacances
les cocotiers la mer bleu turquoise et c
est donc le développement touristique la
plaisance etc
mais comment est-ce que nos territoires
et départements d'outre-mer peuvent
vraiment tirer parti de cette croissance
bleue
qu'est ce que est ce qu est ce qu il ya
des enjeux spécifiques qu'on n'aurait
pas évoqué ce matin
oui alors plusieurs axes déjà et là je
fais référence à maud fontenoy on doit
mieux avoir une meilleure connaissance
de nos fonds marins pour mieux les gérer
et mieux les protéger c'est vraiment le
premier axe on a décidé de voir avec les
républicains moins de 5% des fonds
marins sont aujourd'hui cartographier
d'où un réel besoin d'accroître notre
connaissance en fait de ses fonds marins
avec la double perspective d'une
conservation de la biodiversité pour une
exploitation durable de nos ressources
et respectueuse du milieu marin et le
développement des technologies et
l'intérêt commercial par les grands
fonds lille avance actuellement mais il
est insuffisant donc on a plusieurs
propositions
tout d'abord développer la connaissance
des ressources du milieu là encore
développé un budget on en revient
ifremer revient d'un directement dans
chacune de nos discussions comme comme
un outil de connaissance océanographique
indispensable pour notre avenir
maritimes tout à fait puis renforcer la
recherche interdisciplinaire pour
comprendre mieux la complexité des
grands fonds et puis imaginez pourquoi
pas à paris une grande maison de la mer
un peu à l'image de la cité des sciences
et qu'ils fassent bien sûr une part
belle aux outremers très bien je vous
remercie de ces propositions est ce que
vous voulez ajouter un dernier mot oui
tout à fait on a parlé tout à l'heure
j'en ai parlé un petit peu empreint
bulle de l'énergie thermique des mers et
notamment du projet soit que les initiés
connaissent bien qui grâce à ce projet
soit qui climatise la grande zone de
saint denis jusqu'à sainte marie à la
réunion qui climatise également
l'hôpital de papeete en fait pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas le projet soit
c'est un projet en fait qui fonctionne
de climatisation qui fonctionne par par
extraction d'eau de mer en eaux
profondes et par différentiel d'eau de
mer et donc l'idée c'est de développer
ce genre de projet qui permet non
seulement d'avoir recours à des énergies
autre que les énergies fossiles mais
également de développer d'un point de
vue économique
nos territoires d'outre-mer et en
conclusion je dirais qu'il faut qu'on
voit nos outre-mer aujourd'hui vraiment
comme comme des points de développement
géostratégique et géo conomique de la
france merci beaucoup vous faites déjà
une transition avec une future table
ronde sur l'énergie puisque évidemment
les océans c'est aussi les énergies
marines renouvelables on en parlera tout
à l'heure merci à tous de votre
participation on n'a pas épuisé le sujet
loin s'en faut il ya bien des sujets
qu'on aurait aimé pouvoir évoquer ce
matin ce que le littoral et la mer
concentrent des enjeux qu'il faut
pouvoir concilier mais vous l'avez
compris dans cette première table ronde
nous vous invitons les uns et les autres
à voir l'avenir de la france en bleu et
à préparer à tourner le regard vers la
mer non pas seulement comme un horizon
de vacances mais comme un gisement
d'opportunités et de croissance pour
notre pays merci de votre attention